après des heures de voyage ils sont
épuisés mais c'est sucré n'en sont sains
et saufs désormais de l'autre côté de la
frontière en pologne
honnêtement je n'ai pas de mots on ne
sait pas quoi faire regardez les enfants
comment faire avec eux c'est très
compliqué comme eux selon le
gouvernement polonais 115000 ukrainien
aurait déjà gagné le pays la majorité
fui par la route ou en train comme cette
foule qui tentent de quitter le vif à
l'ouest de l'ukraine des femmes et des
enfants pour la plupart les hommes de 18
à 60 ans doivent rester en ukraine pour
se battre outre la pologne les
ukrainiens rejoignent les autres pays
frontaliers comme la roumanie ou la
hongrie certains tentent même de gagner
l'allemagne à berlin ce centre d'accueil
voit les premiers réfugiés arrivés
encore sonné par ce qui est en train de
se passer
[Musique]
nous pensions que le pire scénario était
de voir la russie envahir l'est des
régions comme lou ans dans le donbass
mais personne n'imaginait que la russie
allait aller plus loin dans toute
l'ukraine
face à l'exode des ukrainiens le centre
prévoit d'augmenter sa capacité
d'accueil
mais nous avons actuellement 1300 places
disponibles et nous en créerons autant
dans les deux trois prochaines semaines
car la vague migratoire devrait
s'intensifier avec la guerre selon les
nations unies 5 millions d'ukrainiens
pourrait être déplacé